so you've got for those listening to
restfully now we do this as a videocast
ladder with credit calm Dana has a new
what is it is it a is it a Bob what do
you call that hairdo I got tired of
having long hair that's what it is
and I I went gradually shorter so I
didn't freak anybody out
but I didn't tell Chris I was doing it
so wait no I wouldn't totally gamble
that one tonight and I went in and I
just cut it off cut it cuz it's been you
know how long it's been
you asked me one time Stephen when we
were in Colorado at the event that
occupiers crashed and like we smelled
them you asked me here like do you have
extensions no because my hair was so
long did she ask you that that's an
incredibly gay question first I was like
are you not straight anymore but um but
no it's just how long my hair was so
anyway I got it off let's do this later
you had me worried for a little bit and
we spoke about this there were about two
appearances where they tried to give you
the big fox news hair and I saw it and I
was like that's not that's not Dana I
hope she doesn't stay with that and then
you got rid of it really quickly I mean
you say Fox News hair I think Priscilla
Presley it's kind of this business it is
it's the wedding photo with Elvis hair
yeah you can put stuff in it
there's cubbies in the back that's what
it's like I mean you know there's
there's an older demo and they just love
the big hair and the gams and that's
what sells no it looks it looks good
it's kind of its kind of whole Aeon Flux
thing go oh I want a on flux hair but I
don't want the catfish whiskers that
come out yeah yeah
and I was like do that and so it was
good hair but terrible motion picture so
data so you have a radio show obviously
nationally syndicated on our wonderful
affiliate here Wham in Detroit but a lot
of people may not necessarily know your
background how you came into it because
you know my background was always
stand-up comedy entertainment and yours
was a little bit different so let's talk
about that cuz you by I realized I was
talking with with your husband you know
a lot of my listeners don't even know
any
thing about my background because I'm
always talking about the news and you
may not necessarily talk with your
audience about this so much so tell my
audience and they can rally the
information oh I used to be a dirty
dirty liberal like the ones that were
like the liberal that was annoying and
and Stephen I am like I also talk with
my hands a lot it's true I'm not I used
to not only be a dirty dirty liberal but
I was also one of those annoying Fembots
feminists like the type who would have
gotten mad about the Bud Light st.
Patrick's Day tweet today but yeah I
used to be I mean maybe not that bad I
mean I wasn't I didn't go into a rage
spiral every time I mean hold the door
open for me but oh my god I hate me in
the past like if we ever if there was a
time machine I wouldn't have to go back
in time to kick my own ass would be
amazing
and hi this one would totally win but no
that's that's in a more educated I
became and the more that I grew up and
matured that's when I started very
slowly converting and being a mom was a
huge part of it but my it's kind of hard
when your whole family is liberal my
whole entire I had no shot my whole
family was liberal and they worked with
with the state party the Democrats in
Missouri my uncle was a delegate for
Barack Obama in 2012 so I really didn't
have I mean and I went to a very liberal
arts university so liberal liberal
liberal liberal liberal not the
Tocqueville kind that's who I was
surrounded by so it was really hard and
then they accused me some members of my
family accuse me of going to the city
and getting brain washed southern was
already say there's an RN wash washed
what I say what's wrong with them with
what what's wrong with people in
Missouri that they have to add an R it's
like it's an it's a it's a false it's a
speech impediment that requires effort
to add something and until it wasn't
until I got into broadcasting and when I
get really tired and or if I have a
glass of wine I don't enunciate as well
okay oh let me ask you real quick okay
up on the blank top tick tick tick
what's the word what's the top of your
house is called a mess okay you say roof
you don't say roof
no because that's what dogs say okay
I've never heard a dog say ruff nor bow
Wow
but there's
are if you Steven if you go to southern
Missouri there's an R and wash it's
either or shore wash depending what we
need to do is take people from Missouri
and send them to England to teach them
how to pronounce an R and then you can
meet at an intersect what is that they
never like we speak English properly
there's an Arn properly whenever I hear
like Charles cook whenever I hear him
talk I just wanted to I secretly in the
back of my head obviously because it's
in the back my head I think you're fake
Englishman your accents fake but he's
not you know he's not but it just sounds
like his diction and everything was too
perfect and so South that's pretty good
actually
South African can sound really fake it
sounds like someone poorly doing an
Australian accent and there was a guy
one time in Charleston and we were in
Campbell California and remember that
because he said you know he started
talking and I said like oh it's as bad
as a Leo and Blood Diamond and he was
like no I'm just from South Africa I'm
like ah that's a terrible Australian
accent we're not friends anymore no I've
never the only time I've ever I don't
think I've ever heard a total proper
South African accent except D Antwoord
the name is drawing a blank right now
should I be okay it's a band it's a band
of South African rednecks if they look
like South African redneck but they have
mullets but it's supposed to be arty I
don't know there's some there's some
great social subjects to that because of
the racism and the apartheid state we
have to go to a break we'll bring you
right back Dana lash ladder with Browder
we are back with the one and only Dana
lash as hoop earrings that are clinking
on her microphone right now so please
forgive her for she knows not what she
does I try not to move my head that I
don't have a lot of I don't wear a lot
of jewelry but I'm like everything
jewelry what are you talking about oh my
god I have like four big necklaces that
people make fun of when I go on fox or
CNN they're like well your husband wears
more jewelry than many women no he just
has the earrings the bracelets well we
have our leather wrist again I know he
looks like something like those kids in
like Captain Planet would wear to
display their powers like earth someone
made that
because they knew we were former goth
kids so somebody made them and that's
what yeah anyway either when I see
bracelets that thick
I think either you're about to go to a
powerlifting meet or they are non
pragmatic in everyday life because it
makes it hard to bend lose your
flexibility but what's cool this is a
weird conversation this uh now that the
listeners have entirely turned off the
dial so Dana okay so your book hands off
my gun so you were a liberal now when
you transitioned you're obviously you're
kind of known I guess one of your
calling cards I should say is the gun
issue I think you know obviously people
like to pigeonhole folks and you offer a
lot more than that but it's an issue
where you've been a strong advocate
clearly were you a leftist who was still
pro-second amendment or were you all the
way like anti-gun when you were to the
left no I was still a leftist who is
still pro-second amendment I mean you
kind of have to be it's weird because
the left in a rural area where all my
family is I mean there's they come from
a town of like 300 people
so you everybody has a firearm but they
don't know they don't really carry a
handgun so much as that everybody has
rifles so everybody has the pickup truck
and you got the gun rack in the back
glass and you got your rifle there and
that's that's just how it was people had
their gun cabinets in the middle of
their living rooms I had a relative that
had a gun cabinet in their dining room
in place of a china hutch so it's that
you just kind of you grow up with it so
and because they hunted we never real I
was never against ever and I was always
constitutional carry for Second
Amendment and there were just I think
that that was part of it there were a
lot of issues that as I grew up I
realized why am i calling myself a
Democrat because I don't agree with them
here here or here but it's just how I
was raised to believe but at my core
being a lot of that stuff didn't jive
it's true you know and that's that's one
thing I talked about if Republicans need
to know a strategy right now first off
far and away the winningest issue are
guns for conservatives a lot of people
they try and paint you as extremists you
know or they that's where they go to
assault weapons they try and muddy those
waters because guns are a very winning
issue because there's a lot of you know
are a lot of Democrats like you
mentioned you are still pro-second
amendment and then you've got feminism
is overreached where people are
rejecting it freedom of speech now since
the Liberals have lined up directly
across from it and then Islamic
terrorism people are okay with calling
Islamic terrorism Islamic terrorism not
the administration so those four issues
the strongest of which I would say are
guns is that why you focused on that do
you think a lot because you think it's a
it's it's something that can reach
across the aisle and appeals to people
other than just rah-rah Republican now I
focused on it because people were
threatening to kill my kids and they
were coming in my house and it and it
took me to yeah so I decided that I was
that it was gonna be a focus because if
somebody's gonna sit here and issue
threats out of one side of their mouth
and then talk about from the other side
of their mouth and disarming me I'm
gonna have a real problem with that
person and so that's I basically the the
book that I wrote hands off my gun I got
so mad I descended into my own to a rage
spiral and I did like massive amounts of
research I had someone assisting me with
research but I did I buried myself in
statistics for over a year so I could
get this book compiled and get it
finished because I was tired of hearing
all of these arguments especially from
people who know absolutely crap about
guns I was so tired of hearing people
sit here and use the words clip and
magazine as though they're two
interchangeable things or use made-up in
a fairy tale unicorn terms like a thot
weapon and I had one chick she's with
the moms demand anti-gun lobbyists
they're like the Bloomberg professional
lobbyists that's what they do is talk
crap about gun owners like what what a
job is that what are those benefits like
you have dental but say she actually
said I don't know if they do I think the
Klan had dental for Robert Byrd but I
don't know if they do but she had said
at one point that an assault weapon is
anything that can fire ten rounds a
minute well holy crap I mean if you have
your things measured out you could fire
ten rounds out of a musket I mean that's
like every single firearm and that's
kind of the point they use on purpose
vague terms so that they can classify
all guns as bad so I just got mad and I
wrote this book is a big giant middle
finger to all those people right well
actually you know what they do use a lot
of turns people to understand and then
sometimes they use terms that actually
do exist for example you know assault
weapon means nothing assault rifle is a
rifle that is used in the military
so assault rifle as a term they go oh
people are to use the term assault rifle
referring to this specific subset of
weapons let's say assault weapon and
they really and even to an extent that's
even kind of an incorrect classification
because anything is an assault whatever
but I mean really what they should be
saying is this has select-fire
capability this does not mean you can
flip the giggle switch on the
military-grade rifle and you can go to
flauta whereas with you know a
semiautomatic rifle one that lacks the
select-fire capability you can't so but
they don't want to get into the
nitty-gritty and all of that because
that those are facts and facts are scary
things to people who need people to
remain uninformed so they can push
paranoia and fear well let me ask you
this III think that there's a huge
contingency and this is where I think
Republicans and conservatives lose it
there are huge contingency of people who
aren't necessarily anti fact I certainly
don't think most people who vote liberal
or anti fact I think they're manipulated
by some people who try to cover up or
subvert facts I think a lot of people
are just misinformed or uninformed so
would you say when you were a liberal
obviously you were someone who you
you've been a truth seeker your whole
life do you just think we were submerged
into an environment where you didn't
have access I was a purposeful dumbass
because it for me it was more about
winning an argument than it was about
being right and I think that's having
been there I honestly think that that's
a huge problem of the left and you know
there's some people that I see on the
right that do this but by and large I
mean how can you be faced with factual
information and not get it we live in
the era of information there is no
excuse at all whatsoever for anybody to
not be able to research a topic and get
both sides of the argument I like I said
I was a willful dumbass I purposefully
stuck too ignorant talking points
because it was more important for me to
win the argument than it was to be right
because if I conceded a point the point
was to me not to be correct the truth
wasn't the focus for me it was about
winning an argument it was about winning
a debate and acting like I was a badass
because I could argue someone even
though I was wrong has not been able to
stand you at all even if you had the Bob
and your little hipster glasses back
then you would
I bet you those are non prescription
lenses totally yeah you know I did you
were the girl who was the bane of my
existence in college because I remember
you know and I'm glad to meet you hi now
but we had girls like that I have to
live with that I have to listen and
here's the and here's the kicker I have
two sons who now have to put up with
chicks like that in in in this society
touching topic so yes sons and I mean
full disclosure Dana and I and our
families we know each other but yes I
just yeah we don't know each other she
she'd disavows she washes her hands
Pontius Pilate when it comes to publicly
acknowledging me she's like Peter except
there's no there's no rooster crowing
it's just drank my beer a true shiner
cheer which I don't like but you do I
think it's too sweet okay you have two
boys so obviously the stereotype is
right the conservative Christian gun
owner you know cleaners that guy and I
want a free porch you know exactly but
you're pretty protective of your boys
and you talk about this and I don't have
children yet so it's something that is
definitely open my eyes where you talk
about how young girls can be sexually
predatorial
with boys and you felt the need to be
you know that sort of cliched father
with a shotgun for your boys I mean tell
us what that's like in 2015 and and how
has it changed from the boys being
always the pervs and the wrong to girls
sometimes now like here's my chat yeah I
ate Smee because I'm tired I'm tired of
the the whole that what is it that we
heard like all last summer till men
teach men not to rape teach men not to
rape
okay well let's hashtag teach women to
be ladies not that hard is it let's
teach women to learn how to be ladies I
know how ladies are cuz I am one I know
how girls are cuz I was a little girl at
one point I was a teenage girl at one
point and this idea that one sex bears
all of the responsibility for every
single thing in life is is sexist
inherently it's idiotic and it's unfair
to young boys I feel like there's a war
on young boys I feel like there's a war
on boys period because they society
comes down on them so hard
everything from title 9 to all of this
other the abortion on demand the
feminist crap that we hear about day
day out if they even hold the door open
for a lady now there was a poll taken or
not a poll taken but a story written
about how well really that's still
inherent sexism okay then get your own
damn door broads I'm tired of this stuff
I'm tired of men constantly being
attacked and Steven honestly that was
one of the single biggest things that
was like the the the lever that just
kicked it all off that's how I started
on the path to actually acknowledging
that okay maybe I am a conservative
because I brought a young man into the
world a boy that I am raising into a
young man and I had to come face to face
with the fact that all of the biggest
demons that he is going to have to
battle in his life are things for which
I used to advocate and use all of my
power to promote and and and make ever
more prevalent in society and so part of
my punishment I think are part of my
coming to terms with that is I'm gonna
now help my young men navigate all of
those landmines that I set my past is a
progressive feminist well that's a
mouthful I got landmines and I thought
about when I stepped outside and Hopper
was in the backyard and now that the
snow is melted it's been a very
unpleasant experience but appreciate
your point no it's true listen I mean I
gotta tell you I mean it there there is
a noticeable shift and certainly as a
male no matter the problem is you have
to apologize before you say anything
there have been women who've made
aggressive passes at either me and my
friend older right old particularly
outside there was a situation at a gym
with what one would now call a cougar
where if I were to do what she had done
to me I'd be hauled off in cuffs and if
I did it and it went public and people
said hey that's sexual harassment
I would hang my head and say you know
what put me in the stocks I deserve that
women are aggressive I actually dealt
with a situation like that recently at
SHOT Show with a older woman going after
my husband Steven was she a biker chick
no she was not laughing come on it's a
reasonable assumption he's got if I can
go into the full story but no is FCC
regulated but let's hear it no I had I
don't think I can't I'm like it's not
that I said a curse word because they
didn't it was just what I said
it probably wasn't totally ladylike for
me to say but I
that it really loud enough for the whole
place to hear cuz you know me but now
this woman had like and my husband just
is not you know into that stuff he was
walking around our friend Grady Powell
who is in ultimate survival Alaska we
were at one of those events after a day
of sessions at shot show in Vegas it was
I think it was an event sponsored by
Glock and we were there and we were
talking with everyone and this woman was
like super ridiculously aggressive
towards my husband like really late
getting up there getting into a space
and I'm like my husband's a grown man he
can handle himself you know I don't need
that we've been married for 15 years and
we got two kids I think I got a flag up
you know what I'm saying
so but she kept going she at one point
remarked about his mustache at which
point I said oh it's she going to the
mustache fried territory something like
that
hell I did I said I was going to later
on so later parts of us will need to be
dumped on air but no I mean it's so
aggressive there was I don't want to
embarrass any ladies and I don't really
like to talk about you know my kids
private lives because they're this
digital let's bring you on after and
then without embarrassing huh you'll
explain a little bit louder was crowd
our Dana lash right back with Dana lash
she was about to reveal some painfully
embarrassing your children and
aggressively women okay so give us give
us the gist cuz I know a little we've
talked about this I know I told you some
of it well and it's and it's hard as a
parent because you I don't want to hover
over my kids and I want them to be able
to make good decisions on their own but
at the same time so you just want to go
so my son had been dealing with a young
lady who actually had been a part of a
youth group of what she was a member and
you know every year kids have phones and
had been really aggressively like
texting and you know the selfies with
the stock clips and all that stuff and I
just thought that some of what was that
face again it was in the dark okay just
listening to rest early right now Dana
lash looks like the situation from
Jersey Shore when she's doing the Seas
it looks like my mouth look like a
baboon's ass that's what it looked like
that should I just did Dana you do
enough radio you know you can't say that
on air yes you can no okay continue the
story it looked like a baboon's potox
okay that's what my mouth look like
Stephen
okay she's gray so this girl was texting
just you know a little it was just a
little inappropriate I think and not
something that a 13 year old young lady
needed to be texting my son now I didn't
get on the phone and text for him I
didn't do any of that and I just you
know said something to my son I'm like
well you know you want to make sure that
the women of your acquaintance are
acting like ladies and just remember
that you know it can get worse as they
get older and he handled it just fine
all by himself and he had told her that
he didn't appreciate her behavior and he
thought that she needed to act a little
bit more like a lady and stop making a
fool of yourself in front of my parents
because we had been at church and some
you know anyway hit right click save
yeah but like you that was like such an
epic handling and he but he was really
nice would you do he was he was nice and
he wasn't trying to personally offend
her right and at the same time he was
saying look I think your behavior could
be had been better and I was just like
huh what you did though what you did
correctly you know knowing you and your
husband is a lot of times parents just
go you know she's not a lady don't you
know don't talk to it that's that's bad
I'm not letting you talk to any more
they don't explain the reason behind you
know this is what a man looks for in a
woman this is if a man finds a wife he
finds what is good and this is what you
want in a wife this is the purpose to
dating and I know I mean you sort of
just glossed over it but I know you
teach that to your young man and a lot
of people don't they just say don't do
this don't do that and that's one thing
I'm internally grateful from my father
and I know your husband does it we can
refer to him by name if one knows it's
Chris so I'm just like I'm sorry like
trying to keep it private but everyone
knows he's on Twitter he has his
mustache has its own bra
everyone knows Chris a lot of a lot of
fathers don't do that so even if there's
a father in the household or a mother in
the household there really isn't a
father and a mother
right no I agree with that and I think
it's really important to make that
distinction and the way I look at it and
and one of the things you know even
though my advice is that I say the word
edible snakes way too much that's my big
vice but one of the things that I always
do is I mean I'll say a little prayer
for whoever and my kids you know future
wives are gonna be yeah that's really
important as well I I'm I'm keeping in
mind that we're teaching him to look for
someone with whom he's gonna spend the
rest of his life and who's gonna be a
member of our family he's gonna be
raising my grandbabies at some point you
know haven't heard that that's still
like four years off but it's it's
important and I want him to be able to
make that decision intelligently and I
want him to be able to have that that I
don't know emotional IQ I say if she
lacked better way to put it to be able
to identify those traits or lack there
were two and lack thereof in a woman and
it's really important to to not just
tell our boys that but also to show them
I remember one time when they were still
pretty young we were in the toy line at
Target and heard toy aisle and I took
him down to the toy aisle and I showed
them the Bratz dolls and I said don't
ever bring home a girl that wears this
much makeup to mama
because I'll turn on the hose and I'll
hose her off on the walk and then you
come home from your TV hit pay no no
it's provided by it's done by
professionals and I will never wear
purple up here that's true you know I I
mean it's I think it's really important
to teach boys that and at the same time
it's also unteach it's important to
teach women what to look for those good
virtues and a man but it's also good to
teach women which we talked about
empowering women why can't we empower
women to be virtuous women why is virtue
looked at as though it is a negative
instead of a positive because ultimately
you know and that's those are the kind
of women that men gravitate towards when
it concerns picking out someone to be
there they're not the scumbags and you
know what's more empowering if I know
feminists are already going to get mad
about this because I'm not saying it's
necessary right but what's more
empowering to a strong woman than a
strongman who undergirds her in some
values women who find who take personal
offense like that they don't know and I
will say this very slowly so there's no
mistaking in my words they don't
understand what a partnership is that is
what a successful partnership is that is
what a successful marriage is I wouldn't
be able to do everything that I am able
to do without my husband there with me
and vice versa it is not for a lack of
strength that I say this it is to
acknowledge the strength that is in my
union with him and those who don't
understand that like I said they simply
do not understand partnerships no that's
absolutely right they understand
partnerships everywhere else I guess if
you were gay or if your partnership
involves going into the ladies restroom
hand-in-hand at Planet Fitness then
they'd be cool with it by the way where
all the rape culture activists with that
were allowing tallywackers in women's
locker rooms because I looked at that as
though it was an attack on women it was
an assault on women I I'm not gonna
apologize for feeling uncomfortable
being in a dressing room with a man and
it's a man I don't care how much
lipstick you want to put on it anyone
who thinks that the sum total of a woman
is some cosmetics from the Macy's
counter or from Sephora that's insulting
if they think that's the sum total of
what a woman is is the makeup that she
puts on and the clothes that she or even
they're private that's sexist yeah
exactly and women are more than just
being a vagina and boobs though those
are one could argue I know every day my
husband probably giving you a silent
amen and yes I found that offensive the
fact that that was that the woman was
she was slut-shamed the same
slut-shaming that you see feminists or
that feminists complain about that was
done to the woman who said I'm really
uncomfortable with the man being in the
locker room I'm not ever gonna apologize
for for being watchful over my security
women are told Steven you know this
women are told if you see something say
something be constantly aware of your
surroundings unless it's political
fitness beats down the human spirit I
mean that first off you know for example
they and we talked about this in the
video that's going up here where I did
go undercover into Planet Fitness as a
lady I didn't go into the transgender by
the way
that's our liberal replied I've got I
went in as a woman if you want to call
me transgender that's on you I dressed
up as a woman just like President Hoover
I just did a little bit of
cross-dressing I don't necessarily
contribute transgender here's the deal
yeah it was brethren humor it wasn't the
vacuum guy yeah it was President Hoover
anyway the point I don't even what my
point was we got way off yeah they strip
people of their independence and rugged
individualism by removing a squat rack
because it intimidates people yeah well
it's give an example a squat rack no it
was a proactive decision to get rid of a
squat rack because it intimidated people
so it's at a certain point you're
excluding somebody right wait hold up
I'm sorry I can't get past that do they
or do they don't have any squat racks at
Boniface anymore why would anybody go to
Planet Fitness exactly a self-respecting
woman go to planets they emptied some
tootsie rolls they have people in rolls
how do you do leg day if you don't have
a squat rack you don't you go in as a
fat person and you leave as a fat person
who feel good about being a fat person
with a couple extra tootsie rolls in
your stomach literally they do have
tootsie rolls and pizza they're pizza
what is it jarred pizza night every like
second Monday of the month I don't know
they do have pizza night at Planet
Fitness and bagel bagel day so that's it
but it's a business model people need to
understand that and this is the sort of
the absolute education of men no it's
not the business model of Planet Fitness
is very simple it's not to get people
stronger and healthier what it is is to
get people to sign up and have the
minimum amount of membership dues to be
paid so that they don't cancel the
auto-pay so they're perfect customers
someone who pays that $10 a month and
never sets foot in the gym and minimizes
traffic that's the business model it's
just low enough so that you don't cancel
the auto-pay that's why they don't have
a squat rack they're dumbbells go up to
60 pounds anyway we've got yeah I know I
know
it's Horne Jem has three squat racks and
I forgot how high the dumbbells go yeah
you're probably not going much higher
than 60 let's be honest but your husband
I will get there at some point I'm at
thirty I'm halfway there what do you
think doing those for what do you use I
do curl
then I do my tries and technical terms I
need not concern myself with this muscle
okay well we got off that just gave me a
stroke really but we have three three
squat racks I'm not even gonna get into
the I called someone I used what squat
racks are for and they go in there do
some well I called another gym today and
she said well we have a smith machine I
said no but you miss quite wreck she
said well it's the same thing I said no
no are you a personal trainer she said
yes I said okay I want you to go back to
school I want you to hand in your degree
I want you to fire yourself and
re-educate yourself because you cannot
squat in a smith machine it's not the
same thing I don't know what a smith
machine it's on a track so it's not free
weight you know that's like the squat
rack but it's on a on an immovable track
so it only goes up so you don't have to
balance it so it's part of the workout
yeah I know
anyways you're only gonna make me mad
and then I need to go get to you know I
was just like I totally new totally I
went off into the weeds um no I went off
into it too because we've been doing
this video all week and just the
backlash from people who Planet Fitness
and do a whole video on planet Venus we
absolutely could we should get on squats
well I do actually mark Repetto is
coming on he's a big conservative and he
wrote starting strength and he actually
writes for PJ Media every now and then
so and it's so funny let me let me say
this cuz I don't know about you but when
I heard of Planet Fitness right and I
heard the lunk alarm no judgement zone
no squats are allowed no deadlifts these
are rules right no dead lips either well
people can watch the video ladder with
credit calm the alarm went off when I
was working out as a woman so we push
the boundaries there are they where does
their acceptance of transgender people
start and their judgement of lumps begin
because I heard those lines these are
part of their policies and it's but when
I saw those policies I said that's a
liberal company boy does it have to be
little conservative I said you know why
because no conservative needs to put up
a sign that says we're going to exclude
successful people and serious trainings
no conservative business would exclude
successful people that's that whole
occupy one-percenter we want everyone to
feel good about themselves that's
liberal ISM to a tee and you're seeing
it now obviously have
show everyday people here on Wham we're
we're talking right now but for people
online who are watching this on the
youtubes where can people find you
Dana radio.com and my show on the blaze
6 p.m. Eastern 5 central which you have
been on on Monday through Friday yes I
have been well I'm not on Monday through
Friday but I've been on the show but you
have been on the show raised it oddly
and you could have potentially been
lying to my audience and so for that we
must punish you and send you on your way
subscribe by clicking my face or click
this video next to me
it's playing right now in a box how do
we do that
that's the magic of the Internet is it
still playing still playing I don't want
to look at it still playing isn't it